Now we can try to calculate the most similar case of the new problem based
solely on the origin. The two dimensional grid here tries to represent both all
the cases and in your problem. Of course we can also calculate the similarity of
the new problem with the old cases based on destination. This two dimensional
grid captures the cases and the problem based on the destination. You
can compute the [UNKNOWN] distance from Q in all the cases placed on the origin,
shown here. And you can do the same thing with the destination, shown here.
If we focus only on the origin, then the B case seems the closest. If we focus
solely on the destination, the E case seems the closest. However, the B case is
not very good when we look at the destination. And the E case is not very
good when you look at the origin. How then might an AI agent find out which is
the best route of all of these choices? How might it decide D is the best route?